Is Steve Bay going to get another shot
at? It should. Huh? You know what I mean?
This is what people are thinking
and people thinking, you know,
the guy fights wins more
UFC title defenses than
anybody in the history of the
sport. Three becomes a, you know, the
most accomplished heavyweight of all time.
I mean,
you think about what he's done.
Do you think about the fact that he
knocks off for BC over doomed to win the
title? He knocks out ouster
over and defend the title,
knocks out junior dos Santos stops,
uh,
beats Francis when everybody's
terrified of Francis. I mean,
he became the most accomplished
heavyweight of all time. Right?
Then he gets knocked out in the first
round of crazy perfect punch by Daniel
Cormier and a perfect strategy
and you got to go. Well, he, uh,
for sure I'd like to see a rematch.
It's like,
when do you want to see them beat
somebody first and then have a rematch?
I actually want to see,
but for me, Dan Daniel, me,
I've always said is the most impressive
fighter to ever step in the octagon in
terms of his stature. I just
think he's incredible, right?
He said to me the best I want
to see him fight Jon Jones.
I know that John John's,
they say Islamic.
Phil is where the big money's
on him versus Brock. Okay.
So even with Alexander Guts, when all this
tool, five donkeys Yoel mail, he's like,
well that's not happening.
Yeah, I'm retiring in March.
We ready to go January worsen.
Just ask for a title shot now after
he just beat Glover. And so, you know,
he said something like, Hey, you know,
like I love the UFC is
going to be as Brock.
The fight is broad questions.
The narrative guys. Ken Brock,
pass tests. Look at me. Yeah. Yeah.
You know, how long do you
need to go back? Goes out.
How long do you need before?
It's like dancers. Never.
Brian Gustafson opens up on crazy
situation taking him off UFC two 27th this
year's. Well, it, what's, what
happens, we'll talk about it. Oh,
he won't talk about it
then how is he opening up?
Cut will cause people were like,
oh you won't find Anthony Smith but you'll
fight DC or you'll find a heavyweight.
But now all of a sudden injured and they
fight Anthony Smith versus Shogun was a
fight that I was concerned about.
I thought shogun retire. Yeah.
However he won three in a row.
If you would have one that I wanted to
see him get a tough shot against DC cause
I went to DC to get paid.
Well show gun is,
he was ranked I think
eighth eight for this fight.
But even though he's not that old.
How old is Shogun?
134 how old corridors and fight
world fucking Brazilian tortoise.
The unibrow. How old is showing up? I
think it's like 36 right? He's my age.
Is he 36 year old older even though
he's 36 like look when Bernard Hopkins,
who's 36 is when he knocked out
Tito Trinidad is in his prime.
His prime when he beat
Kelly Pavlock he was,
I think he was close to 40 or all
it might have been 42 and yeah,
so that's not a Kelly Palette
killer. Yeah. Not for everybody.
It doesn't mean that they're
past their prime, but Shogun,
I've in so many wars and he got knocked
out by Dan Henderson, Stephane brother.
Everybody's different. In 19 came on
the Grand Prix. It's terrifying, man.
Pride days too. It was different.
Different world, different world.
The drugs and don't like,
and now we got the grant snitch.
It's such a different
environment. Yeah, man.
You'd never know who was doing
what back then when they were at,
there was a mother fuckers five.
He's a town on the fucker.
Let's not just propel them to fight
gusts. No, no, no, no. Dude, let me them.
While he was ready, he was ready.
He wanted the fight looking.
Here's the argument for it.
The argument for it is he knocks out,
were shot on short notice. He knocks
out shogun and then he'll say, look,
I'll take this fight to,
that guy's rolling and he's
a veteran. He's got momentum.
You don't know, fight the fight. The
most intriguing fight to me would be,
I mean it's not Brock and I liked that.
I liked PROC DC because DC gets
paid by me. The only reason,
but the demo,
the most intriguing to me and a lot of
ways would be y'all out Ramiro at two oh
five and deal with that weight
cut with Daniel Cormier.
Well, cornea was like, Nah,
Nah, you can't lose at this fight.
And you miss wait, go. Yeah, sure.
And you miss wait, smart. But
then Yo L's like, listen DC,
you cheated when you made weight.
You know you were pushing down that
towel that one time. Okay, that one time.
That one time. That was real. We want to
talk about cheating and for ELL to DC.
What are you saying? A branch.
Dual gate. Oh, still get here.